will the Skywalker saga end by finally
putting to rest questions over a certain
characters parentage according to some
fresh rumors posted on the fan site
making Star Wars there's a chance that
rise of Skywalker will do just that
warning these are unsubstantiated rumors
attributed to anonymous sources so take
them with a grain of salt
perhaps wash down with some green milk
in other words potential spoilers ahead
making Star Wars editor-in-chief Jason
Ward claims the rise of Skywalker takes
audiences to an end or like tree-covered
Planet immediately after the opening
crawl there it said that a pair of Jedi
wearing white helmets are seen dueling a
green lightsaber against a blue
lightsaber
it's then revealed that the two Jedi are
Luke and Leia appearing as the younger
versions of themselves as seen in Return
of the Jedi rumor has it that this
flashback sequence not only demonstrates
how Leia was able to summon the force
and save herself from certain death and
space in the last Jedi but also sets up
a plot in which Leia trains Rey
throughout the rise of Skywalker
which leads Rey to make an important
decision following a major revelation
she's a member of the Palpatine's family
yep rumor has it that Rey is a
descendant of Emperor Palpatine the
villain otherwise known as Darth Sidious
who destroyed the Jedi Order led the
Galactic Empire and was a mentor to
Darth Vader apparently Rey discovers
she's a Palpatine and decides to reject
her parentage renaming herself as a
Skywalker at the end of the film thus
explaining why the movie is titled the
rise of Skywalker as far as rumors go
this one doesn't set off a whole lot of
alarms race parentage has always been a
point of contention amongst fans most of
whom aren't satisfied with the idea
presented by kylo Ren in the last Jedi
that raised mother and father were
nobodies and alcoholics to boot the last
Jedi writer director Rian Johnson has
said that the mystery of Rey's parentage
hasn't been actively resolved revealing
in January 2018 that anything still open
since he isn't involved with the rise of
Skywalker it was reported in April 2018
that JJ
Abrams who wrote and directed the force
awakens and the rise of Skywalker
actually had a different plan for Rey's
identity than the one presented in the
last Jedi
Simon Peck the actor behind the jakku
junk boss unkar plutt said during an
appearance on the happy sad confused
podcast that what abrams had intended to
eventually reveal about Rey's parents
was quote undone slightly by the last
Jedi he added that there was talk of Rey
having a relevant lineage rather than
being a child of two alcoholic traders
from jakku Daisy Ridley herself has
mentioned that Palpatine plays a pivotal
role in the upcoming movie going so far
as to say that the infamous vadi is
quote very instrumental to the plot of
the film and that there's an important
reason for his return she told IGN in
August 2019 it's not like he just
appears again it's all explained could
the rise of Skywalker explained that
Palpatine returned to lure his kin to
the dark side of the force
leaving the resistance that much more
vulnerable and the first order that much
more powerful maybe after all it could
help shed light on why recent footage
from the rise of Skywalker showed Rey
wearing a dark robe and wielding a
double bladed red lightsaber perhaps Rey
gets entangled in a moral quandary
pulling away from the light side and
potentially considering converting to
the dark side when possible temptation
proves too strong this is far from the
first Rey is a Palpatine rumor we've
heard over the years fans have been
speculating for quite some time now that
Rey is connected to Emperor Palpatine
with some even believing that Rey is
technically both the skywalker and about
the team with the idea that Palpatine
made Rey as a clone of Luke from the
hand he lost in the Empire Strikes Back
it's a wild theory for sure but it could
explain why Emperor Palpatine returns in
the rise of Skywalker to retrieve the
stolen clone and bring her to the dark
side there's also a pretty good chance
that this rumor isn't anything of
consequence and that what actually ends
up happening in the rise of Skywalker is
nothing that anyone has theorized thus
far
perhaps the Skywalker who rises in the
upcoming film isn't
ray or even a single person but a new
generation of force users now known as
Skywalker's we won't know for sure until
well we know for sure when the rise of
Skywalker reveals all on December 20th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]